uh let's return to the October
Revolution and Lennon
what was the October Revolution what uh
who was Lenin what are some interesting
aspects of this this human being and
also this moment in history that stand
out to you that are important to
understand I think the
interesting thing about Lenin is he was
a zealot
and he was a visionary
and he really kind of meant it and I'm
skipping ahead a little bit but Lenin
also was someone who was strategic so at
a certain point when they were trying to
advance uh communism throughout the
Soviet Union and the costs were
outweighing the benefits he did a
strategic Retreat he that did the New
Economic Policy you had a rise of kind
of these small capitalists coming back
you could hire people again and for the
hardcore people in the Soviet Union
hardcore Communists this was a huge
betrayal it's a step back he didn't do
it because he was some kind of crypto
capitalist he did it because he's like
all right we know where we got to get to
but we have to go at a certain pace and
we have to adjust as we go along so to
have someone who is that much of an
ideologue and that much of a Visionary
but still to have any element of
pragmatism to him is I think a very rare
uh uh combination and that pragmatism do
you think that's ultimately where things
go wrong sort of um
that's where you sacrifice the ideas
pragmatism is in this case was good
because by taking a step back you know
he kind of gave himself some breathing
room to allow the revolution to continue
to win the civil war there was a big
moment where Germany if it's it's just
there's lots of like little funny
anecdotes that I learned while
researching this book so you know they
were uh Germany and Russia they were
negotiating uh still a ceasefire because
they wanted Germany wanted to rush out
of the war and basically Germany was
like all right you we will let you leave
but you have to sign this treaty and
basically hand over all this land that
we're currently occupying it was uh just
parts of Ukraine parts of Poland and
Lenin tells Trotsky to stall he's just
just run the clock because he was of the
belief that now that they've taken power
in Russia you're gonna have a worldwide
workers Revolution so just like just
just stall them and he stall he stalled
at a certain point Germany's like all
right you're signing this tomorrow or
we're invading and Trotsky basically
said yeah so so we're leaving the war
but we're not signing anything and the
Germans are like what it's like yeah
well that's what we're doing so hey
um and basically eventually he had to
sign the treaty and Seed huge paths to
land and a lot of money and this was a
very uh precarious moment for him to
maintain control of Russia and people
were telling him like you've lost huge
amounts of territory you know you you've
blown it you should be in jail and he's
like watch your mouth because if you
look for the future it'll be clear which
one of us is more likely to be the one
ending up in jail and he was absolutely
right
uh this was Trotsky or Lennon this is
Lenin saying this to Carl radic ah so
who are these figures here who's Trotsky
who's Lenin who's Stalin what are some
interesting aspects of all of this would
it sort of just to linger on it the
personalities the ideas that were
important well Trotsky came late to
bolshevism he was really the brains in
many ways of the October Revolution he
was an amazing strategist he never
forgot that he was amazing strategist
had a very high opinion of himself and
by the way the October Revolution 1917
that's a key moment
um
of course the the Russian Revolution
lasted a long time but this was a key
moment of uh what a phase shift towards
success
of the Bolsheviks well that was the
moment that was like all right we are
the government now and now we have to
make it's a you know like Thomas
Jefferson said I think it was Thomas
Jefferson or no it's Ben Franklin uh a
republic if you can keep it it's like
all right we've made our own kind of
government if we can keep it because
that was the big question you got an
international blockade you know the
white armies the tsars forces who want
to restore zaraism or at least the the
parliament from uh right before Landon
took over so this was a big kind of no
one's was you know in some ways it was
like the 2016 election it's like all
right we vote in Trump what's this going
to look like like no one no one had any
idea of what a trump presidency was
going to look like all we knew was this
guy's on Twitter running his mouth he's
insulting people and he's had all these
views somewhere over here some over
there and the funny thing is the
Russians hacked both elections
see that's true it was Putin in the
gremlin so Trotsky was you know Lenin's
right-hand man
um and he was you know enormous and to
this day a he remains this kind of
figure who is
supposedly a less authoritarian
anti-stalinist version of Communism that
people can endorse and Stalin of course
was Lenin's successor at first there was
a triumvirate running Russia as Lenin
was recuperating from Strokes then very
quickly not very quickly but gradually
and then suddenly Stalin became an
absolute dictator and he had a series of
of purges and so on and so forth which
solidified his control over the country
and of course for Stalin Trotsky later
but throughout as you write seemed to
almost take on a supernatural character
wherein everything that went wrong in
the USSR was due not just to his views
but to his direct orders from abroad and
uh of course George Orwell brilliantly
and probably my favorite book of his
which is animal farm and also in 1984.
portrayed Trotsky as a a snowball in
Animal Farm and Emmanuel Goldstein in uh
1984 is this embodiment of this evil
that will always have to be fighting
then you need that in order to hold
on to power you always have to have that
enemy right so that I mean that's
something I talk about uh in in the
white pill as well when things start
going wrong they always have to have
scapegoats right and there's this
Russian egg dot you know what the
Russians like to do is you can't say
things out loud but if you make jokes
you can say unspeakable truths and
there's this one anecdote where there's
a Russian leader and things are going
bad and he looks in his drawer and there
were two letters from his predecessor
and he opens the first letter in a panic
and the letter says you know for advice
and the letter says blame everything on
me so he goes out there and he's like oh
my predecessor sucked he was terrible
blah blah it's his fault and everyone's
like okay and then there's a Calamity
again and he's like her crap so it goes
back at his desk and he reads the second
one and it says sit down and write two
letters so when things start going wrong
as they constantly did throughout the
history of the Soviet Union uh or any
you know totalitarian authoritarian
country it's someone has to be the blame
since we know that our idea theology is
true and scientifically true if it's not
working in reality given the Perfection
of the ideology someone must be
intentionally undermining it and causing
the disconnect between thought and
reality and in the Soviet Union there
were there was the kulaks at one point
then it was the Wreckers uh the doctors
it was just different the cap there was
always someone and Trotsky uh was called
a fascist and was accused of plotting
with Hitler and all this other stuff